let me tell you one thing okay talking I
love how everybody now tries to make a
big deal out of one thing that you say
like I don't think I revealed anything
crazy
I'm one way all right Eric was gonna be
sick no I was like he's referring to the
sting that now he's like trying to make
like like I had a pig's nose no no I was
gonna have me I was gonna ask you is Tom
Holland a spoiler nobody crazy that I
mentioned is is would not be annoyed you
mention s I'm out I said Michael Douglas
I'm like is my go-to moment in the movie
that I was in this movie as you looked
around what was it like taking in that
you're in a movie that probably is going
to be the highest-grossing well be
involved
I always said like I feel like this
movie's gonna break all those almanaque
records you know I said down I mean I
just feel like yeah you know you're
gonna look on Monday for example Monday
it's gonna be crazy just just to stand
there and look around
hey everybody its Charlie you may have
heard websites reporting about Sebastian
Stan talking about Avengers four scenes
all explain what's going on
we're doing a new round of that Red Dead
Redemption or spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Marvel
related comment on the video uh name a
new winner at the end of this so during
that clip the interviewer is asking
Sebastian Stan did you talk about some
Avengers for scenes and he tries to
double back a little bit like I didn't
give anything away but the funny thing
is is that right after that Anthony
Mackie leans in and says wait a minute
is Michael Douglas in this film and
Sebastian Stan confirms it and says
there's no one that's not in
this film basically saying that every
MCU character has some kind of role in a
scene in Avengers 4 although obviously
not all them are really important to the
actual plot of the film mostly focusing
on Michael Douglas and Michelle Pfeiffer
the whole reason the interviewer was
asking him about this was because of an
earlier interview he did with a new
source talking about having a scene with
Michael Douglas and Michelle Pfeiffer
and how flabbergasted he was because
there's such amazing actors like I
couldn't believe it all these characters
together the actual quote he gave during
that was there was this one scene I
think we had where everybody was there I
can't really talk about that scene but I
knew it took them three months in
planning this scene to have everybody
there you look around and you just see
everyone from samuel l.jackson to
michael douglas
to Michelle Pfeiffer everybody was there
so why just kind of stood in the corner
and looked and wanted to see how
everybody was going to react it was
surreal so he's talking about a scene
where everyone's on-screen together
there's really like four things that
that could be it's not that many Ford
they have to completely change
everything we know about the MCU from a
story standpoint implying that reality
will fundamentally change by the end of
the movie so they have to have a moment
to address that three they have to setup
how all the character relationships will
be different going forward if Avengers
four is about fixing things
fixing the character relationships like
The Avengers are all broken apart
Captain America Iron Man fixing their
relationship as well as fixing the
universe because Thanos erased half of
all life part of the big reason why Hank
Pym has never worked with the Avengers
before is because he never trusted
Howard Stark our shield he went full
hermit to keep them from getting his Pym
particles and it's implied that that's
no longer gonna be a concern going
forward he'll probably start trusting
the Avengers and working with them on a
limited basis Hank Pym and Janet Van
Dyne though kind of come hand-in-hand
she's a brilliant mind with this deep
knowledge about the quantum realm which
will be big going forward into phase
four so anything he does with the
Avengers would probably involve her so
even if Hank and Janet never formally
joined the Avengers they have to have a
moment where everybody agrees how things
are going to be different between them
going forward like we're all gonna try
and work together to be heroes but to
there also has to be some kind of
remembrance or memorial for any of the
heroes that sacrifice themselves or
seemingly died just remember life and
death are very fluid terms in comic book
movies but obviously they can't win
without some great sacrifice otherwise
there's no big payoff at the end of the
film so they have to have some sort of
remembrance of that then number one
probably the easiest way to do this
giant crowd shot in a happy moment is to
pay off Iron Man and Pepper Potts
wedding which would be a really
celebratory moment so everybody's happy
and it's practically easier to shoot
because all the actors and the
characters are just sitting in rows of
pews right next to each other all
crammed in like sardines wherever it is
if it's inside a church or it's outside
wherever they would have that wedding
none of the actors though have confirmed
that there's a wedding scene but I've
done a few videos about how some deleted
scenes and foreshadowing have told us
that that's probably how they intend on
ending Avengers 4 current leading theory
that if you make all these big
sacrifices and you lose some of your
heroes how do you end the movie on a
happy moment you pay off that wedding
and make sure that Wang gets a seat
right up front but let me know in the
comments if there's a scene with
everybody on screen together what do you
think that scene is going to be there
was also a quote that he gave about
running into Hugh Jackman talking about
x-men and Avengers stuff in the future
at Disney so I'll play this clip here
with the changes in corporate Hollywood
you know with Fox and Disney and such
there's a chance to see potentially
someday and the Avengers versus the
x-men I wonder if that's something
that's a it's kind of fun to think about
or with the Fantastic Four and you could
play two characters
like a little Parent Trap right I doubt
they'd ever let me do that though yeah
well there's the invaders to and that's
to the members of the fortune can i or
kcb says recently i happen to be sitting
next to Hugh Jackman at this Wow all
right here we go so wow I I didn't know
that what other awkward thing I could
talk about but to be like am I gonna see
soon I don't know and but he said a
couple of things to me and I'll just
I'll just leave it at that because I
feel like otherwise I'm gonna get into
trouble with somebody but no you know
but but yeah you know I asked him cuz I
kept thinking I was like he said whether
or not that was Logan was supposed to be
the last
Wolverine thing or whatever and and it's
you know he'd said to me what he's I
think he publicly said out there which
was like he's been thinking about it and
he you know it's on his mind so I don't
know you maybe I think Sebastian
I think phones off please please can you
rewind the last 15 seconds the big thing
about that is the yeah does imply that
Hugh Jackman has been contacted by
Disney because they got the x-men rights
and Hugh Jackman has famously said that
oh yeah I would probably come back and
do bull Vereen for some reason Marvel
got the rights back and they could do
all those characters together I think he
was being a little more tongue-in-cheek
when he talked about coming back for
Disney x-men stuff so I'm not gonna hold
him to that but also let me know in the
comments do you secretly think that Hugh
Jackman will come back for some
Wolverine moment because of all this
x-men Disney merger stuff there's more
Marvel and DC videos that I'm working on
this weekend leave your requests in the
comments below
congratulations Marty Michaels you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here to learn
about the spider-man black costume
deleted scene from infinity war and
click here for more Avengers 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]